Україна досі залишається серед європейських лідерів
за масштабами поширення ВІЛ,
поступаючись антипершістю лише Росії.
За оцінками експертів UNAIDS,
нині з інфекцією живуть близько 250 тисяч українців,
43 тисячі померли від цієї хвороби,
щороку фіксується 15 тисяч нових випадків зараження.
Україна могла би повчитися у Німеччини,
як скоротити кількість нових інфекцій.
Навіть попри те, що коштів на профілактику ВІЛ не вистачає.
Як запевняють німецькі експерти,
гроші - це тільки півсправи.
"Гроші - це далеко не все.
Дуже важлива відкритість!
Один аспект - запобігти інфекції.
Інший аспект - життя з ВІЛ
має бути максимально нормальним.
І це пов’язано з багатьма чинниками.
Наприклад, доступність медичних установ
і боротьба з дискримінацією на робочому місці
та в системі охорони здоров'я.
Тобто, гроші важливі, але це ще не все "
Про те, як побороти суспільні забобони,
йшла мова на конференції, організованій в Берліні
трьома німецькими неурядовими організаціями,
що борються проти СНІДу
СНІД найшвидше поширюється там,
де людей дискримінують, стверджують експерти.
В Україні ця проблема теж існує.
Люди просто бояться тестуватися,
тому що зазвичай бояться не стільки наслідків лікування,
скільки розголосу.
Нетолерантне ставлення в суспільстві.
Але ситуація змінюється на краще.
Навіть за статистикою,
скільки ВІЛ-інфікованих знають про свій статус,
видно, що за останні десять років
із цим стало в п’ять-шість разів краще.
Головне для зупинки епідемії не стільки лікування,
скільки запобігання, переконаний Дмитрієв.
І в цьому сенсі досвід ЄС і, зокрема, Німеччини,
вкрай важливо запозичити.
Німці, приміром, поставили собі за мету,
щоб після 2020 року
не було жодних нових випадків захворювання.
Світовий досвід з профілактики ВІЛ засвідчує,
що ключову роль у вирішенні проблеми
відіграє саме громадянське суспільство.
І в цьому сенсі в України добрі шанси.
В Україні сприятливіша порівняно,
наприклад, з Росією, ситуація, тому що можливостей більше.
Розміри самої епідемії, звісно, великі
і дуже багато проблем,
але є багато можливостей для змін.
Є велика кількість донорів,
є політична воля,
є більш сприятливий для роботи громадянського суспільства клімат,
значно більш сприятливий.
Експертка рекомендує Україні якнайшвидше втілити медичну реформу.
Також зробити прозорими державні закупівлі ліків
і закрити корупційні лазівки,
завдяки яким наживаються недоброчесні виробники й чиновники.
Це дозволить знизити ціни на ліки проти ВІЛ/СНІД.
Але головне - це небайдужість суспільства до цієї проблеми.